Traduttore: Chiara Rodella
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Avete mai pensato al paesaggio
come a una scultura?
Avete mai pensato che una casa, un albero,
possano avere una propria personalità,
una propria identità?
Avete mai immaginato
che un luogo possa avere una sua anima?
Ecco, oggi vorrei portarvi con me
in questa dimensione immateriale
per raccontarvi come sono arrivato
a realizzare delle opere
in grado di dialogare
con quello che gli antichi romani
chiamavano il genius loci,
ossia lo spirito del luogo.
Sono nato e cresciuto a Cambiago,
un paesino dell'hinterland milanese.
A Cambiago, tra una rotonda,
una superstrada, una palazzina anni '70
spuntano qua e là dei cassottelli,
dei cascinotti diroccati.
Alcuni mangiati dalla natura,
altri hanno un albero
che spunta dal tetto,
quasi completamente caduto.
Queste dimensioni sospese
risultano, ai miei occhi,
come una sorta di isolette sacre
in mezzo, a contrasto con l'urbanizzazione
che nel frattempo si mangia
tutto il resto del territorio.
In questo contesto inizio
ad appassionarmi, ad incuriosirmi
del paesaggio, dei linguaggi del paesaggio
e alla sacralità
che vive in alcuni luoghi.
Nel frattempo, finisco gli studi
all'Istituto d'Arte di Monza
e mi trasferisco a 20 anni a Roma,
dove inizio a lavorare come scenografo
in vari campi, tra arte e cinema.
Nel 2013,
un amico mi invita a partecipare
a un festival di arte urbana in Calabria.
E io accetto, spinto anche dall'istinto,
dall'idea, dal desiderio
di voler ritornare a parlare
di paesaggi e di natura.
Arrivo e realizzo la mia prima scultura:
la figura di un uomo,
seduto su un muretto, che guarda il mare.
Voi vi chiederete:
cosa c'entra un uomo seduto su un muro
con il paesaggio, la natura?
Be', l'idea era quella
di raccontare una storia semplice,
una storia quasi invisibile.
E quindi decido di utilizzare
la rete metallica e la trasparenza
per riuscire a realizzare un'opera
che sapesse inserirsi nel luogo
in maniera timida.
Solo che scopro che, in realtà,
la trasparenza aveva
un potenziale molto più grande:
aveva la capacità di raccontare
il luogo attraverso di sé.
Perché il paesaggio disegnava
gli stati d'animo della figura.
E la luce del sole, cambiando,
raccontava i diversi stati emotivi
sempre del personaggio.
Così mi rendo conto
che il paesaggio, in realtà,
era la vera essenza
di cui era fatta la mia prima opera.
Dopo l'esperienza in Calabria,
decido di lasciare
il mio lavoro come scenografo,
e inizio a lavorare in studio
realizzando una serie di sculture.
E inizio anche a girare
in Italia e all'estero,
realizzando delle opere d'arte pubblica,
delle grandi opere d'arte pubblica
come era stato per la prima.
Dopo un periodo di ricerca,
realizzo a Londra "Control".
Con "Control" presento, ufficialmente,
il concetto di materia assente;
ossia, utilizzo la rete e la trasparenza
per rappresentare la materia assente,
che è il lato immateriale delle cose.
Il mio percorso continua, poi,
e inizio ad alternare alle figure
delle geometrie, dei piani, dei cubi,
degli elementi geometrici.
E inizio a realizzare delle installazioni
che creano dei volumi
che non escludono il paesaggio
ma lo includono, valorizzandolo.
Inizio poi a immaginare di realizzare
delle architetture, nel paesaggio,
in cui l'orizzonte delimita il pavimento,
le montagne entrano nelle pareti
e, alle volte, le nuvole decidono
quanto siamo lontani dal cielo.
Così, in Inghilterra realizzo
la mia prima cupola.
E se negli archetipi classici
la cupola rappresenta la volta celeste,
nella mia architettura è la volta celeste
la materia di cui sono fatte.
E inizio a utilizzare
il linguaggio dell'architettura classica
per raccontare la sacralità dei luoghi,
che tanto ricercavo fino a prima.
Con la nuova tecnica, le dimensioni
delle installazioni crescevano,
e avevo finalmente
la possibilità, veramente,
di generare dei mondi inimmaginabili.
Così passa del tempo
e io continuo a lavorare.
E finalmente arriva
la commissione, il lavoro
che mi avrebbe permesso di concretizzare
tutta una serie di riflessioni
fatte sul paesaggio, sul luogo,
sulla sacralità del luogo.
Che è Siponto.
Siponto, per chi non la conoscesse,
è una piccola località
vicino a Manfredonia, in Puglia.
E il parco archeologico di Siponto,
che è questo che vedete,
custodiva le fondamenta
di un antica basilica paleocristiana
che è scomparsa quasi 1000 anni fa.
Così, attraverso la trasparenza,
ricostruisco -
(Applausi)
Attraverso la trasparenza
ricostruisco la basilica sparita:
la riporto, attraverso la sua essenza,
alla sua dimensione più eterea.
Una chiesa sospesa nel tempo,
che mostra principalmente la sua assenza
raccontando la sua storia,
il fatto che fosse sparita;
e al tempo stesso esprime
l'identità e la sacralità
del luogo in cui
è stato fatto l'intervento.
Il progetto Siponto,
oltre a essere un progetto inedito,
è il frutto di una visione
che ha cercato di raccontare il paesaggio
oltre quello che vediamo,
oltre quello che percepiamo.
E quando un progetto ha la capacità
di essere pioniere nel suo campo,
riesce a generare dei nuovi contenuti
e delle nuove prospettive.
Siponto ha generato
delle nuove prospettive
nei campi dell'arte pubblica,
nel restauro,
nello sviluppo del territorio,
nella valorizzazione
del paesaggio e del patrimonio.
Ed è riuscito a farlo
perché ha cercato di raccontare
il patrimonio, il paesaggio
attraverso un'esperienza emotiva,
attraverso la sacralità di un luogo -
attraverso la poesia, principalmente.
Quindi, tornando a noi, che cosa significa
pensare al paesaggio come una scultura?
Che cosa significa scolpire il paesaggio?
Be', scolpire il paesaggio
significa fare di un luogo
un'opera d'arte viva,
che respira e si evolve
con gli elementi del luogo.
Scolpire il paesaggio significa generare
un'esperienza in grado
di metterci in connessione
con l'identità, ma anche
con la sacralità di un luogo.
Io penso che l'arte abbia la capacità
di raccontare questo tipo di storie.
Penso che l'arte abbia la capacità,
e deve avere la capacità
di raccontare la poetica di un luogo.
Perché l'arte, attraverso la poesia,
può darci delle chiavi di lettura
che la sola logica non ci può dare.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)